when did you decide you were going to
begin your own studio when I graduated
from Brooks Institute
I think 1975 believe it or not I was
fortunate enough to occupy a rental
building that had a little teeny office
and from the very beginning of my career
I saw the advantages of having some kind
of exclusive place that I could go to
each day rather than work out of my
house and that extended over time into
me acquiring a studio and then it became
really a great part of the complexion of
my career is to have the tools available
24/7 versus waking up in the morning
producing a movie and renting everything
so I I did what probably is not even
possible anymore but I started to
acquire stuff and save it and I did that
through you know all the years that I've
been in this business which has been
quite a substantial amount of years like
37 I think yeah I've been in the
business doing television and
commercials for at least 20 and but I've
been in the field for 47 years 37 years
yes okay so going back 37 years what did
you envision success to look like versus
what do you envision it now because I
know when someone starts a venture they
have all these grand ideas about how
life's going to be and what is going to
be like everyday to run a business but
then having been in the trenches
I'm sure seven days a week well it's
it's it's a very interesting question
because as I reflect back on my career
you know I was I'm one of the few guys
that actually has a left brain and right
brain where I'm a businessman I'm also a
creative guy and that's an unusual
combination and ultimately I knew from
the very beginning that and this is the
same thing I tell my three daughters you
know if you're lucky enough to find a
career where you can do what you love
the money and all those other things
come later but they do come and
I started from scratch and little by
little I built a business and one thing
leads to another and then finally I
probably at the beginning of the 80s I
started doing what I called hybrid
filmmaking which means I would not only
do still photography I do live-action
and it became a category that's now
taken for granted because everybody
wants sound bites and everybody wants
beautiful visuals so now you can
theoretically do pulls off of a red
camera or the camera you're using right
now and they're usually 2k or 4k and and
you don't even need to bring in a
stuffed Agra fur so I was doing both so
what was the biggest surprise to having
run in business for over 37 years you
know the 80s were a much different time
than it is now social media was the the
whole thing is about reinventing
yourself it's funny as I was driving
into work this morning
you know I it became almost like an
epiphany in my own mind that I'm not
doing anything like what I was doing 10
years ago so I had to basically reinvent
myself and and as I look back in my
career that's all I've done throughout
my whole career is reinvent myself you
become a photographer's what I was for
many years and you all of a sudden wake
up in the morning and go oh my god I've
been working on this one client for four
years inevitably that's great for the
pocketbook but not much for the
advancements and what I want to be doing
creatively so you adapt and it's crazy
because I had one client from ABC that
told me you know why are you getting
that big studio on Hollywood I mean can
you can you really actually make a
living with that big studio and I and I
know this is total cliche but you know
if it's like the Kevin Costner statement
you build it and they will come and lock
down you know because at that time that
I built the studio which was at the end
of around 1999
I built the studio I found myself you
know in a very unique situation that I
didn't even realize which is
people were getting rid of their studios
they were renting them so I became a guy
that actually had my own place and as
crazy as it sounds you know Roger Corman
was a little bit of that motivation and
it was also my desire to create a place
where the creativity could could grow so
you could sit outside and have a
cigarette or lunch and sit down next to
a writer or sit down next to a DP or you
know really take a position of of
collaborating and that was fun you know
did you have entrepreneurs in your
family did you see them novices no not a
single terminal my dad was a Sheep
medalist and my mom you know was a PTA
home housewife I have two siblings and
no I I just lucked out and had a passion
for what I did and I was able to sit
back and go how can I take then and
actually make more of it and just to
finish your first question which relates
directly to you know the formation of
setting up a business and and going
after what you want I'm currently on my
third film now and in this film here is
you know equates to being part of that
vision of working on meaningful projects
in this particular case this movie was
about a it's a romantic comedy but it's
also a pretty strong statement about
edible food and unedible food meaning
fast food and farm-to-table